pour traverser la frontière et arriver
en Ukraine on va prendre un train
celui-ci le trajet il est assez long
pour atteindre qui veut la capitale
parce que faut compter 14 heures de
train et ici il y a beaucoup d'ukrainien
surtout des familles qui font le
déplacement on a aussi croisé une partie
de du staff de l'équipe de football
national
ukrainienne qui rentre d'un match qu'ils
ont joué en Pologne hier on passe en
course avant de prendre le train en
direction de qui
on cherche notre compartiment
bon ça c'est notre train à couchettes
mais il y a quand même des éléments
particuliers déjà vous voyez ici il y a
du scotch sur toutes les vitres pour
faire en sorte que les débris de verre
en cas d'explosion de souffle bah ne
tombe pas et ne viennent pas blesser les
passagers comme ça il reste le plus
possible en place et par ailleurs on
vient de savoir à l'instant que il
fallait éteindre tout simplement les
lumières dans la RAM pour faire en sorte
que le train soit invisible et le moins
visible possible par les Russes du coup
on va l'éteindre tout de suite
[Musique]